- [Narrator] This Barnes & Noble
in Pikesville, Maryland used to be
in a 24,000 square foot
space in this building.
Now it's moved across
the street to a space
that's less than half the size,
and with the downsizing came a new look
and new books chosen specifically
for this store's customers.
It's all part of Barnes &
Noble's strategy to tailor each
of the company's more than
600 locations to local tastes.
- Barnes & Noble is adopting the strategy
of independent bookstores that
it once put out of business.
- [Narrator] Here's how the bookseller
is implementing its new approach
and why it thinks this new
strategy will sell more books.
This is "The Economics of Barnes & Noble."
Barnes & Noble was first founded in 1873.
In 1971, Leonard Riggio
acquired the company,
which set off a period of growth.
The retailer went public in 1993
in an era when it was opening superstores
across the country.
- In the 1990s and 2000s,
Barnes & Noble bookstores really looked
like large supermarkets filled with books,
usually anchoring strip centers
in the suburbs or rural areas.
- [Narrator] And whether in
Phoenix or Maryland or Ohio,
the stores had the same books
with the same furniture
and the same layout.
- It either had one floor or it had two.
If it had two, it had
enormous escalators going up
with this huge sort of
open space in the middle
to an upper floor.
- [Narrator] That model happened
to be extremely scalable.
- They were trying to fill their stores
with books and infrastructure
at the lowest cost possible,
so they wanted to order all
the same types of bookshelves,
the same type of furnishings
and decorations and other accoutrements.
- [Narrator] So the
company grew, and fast.
Those huge stores carried more books
at lower prices than
independent bookstores.
- [Interviewee] We all remember
the rom com "You Got Mail."
- Joe Fox. I'm in the book business.
- I am in the book business.
- So many closed when
Barnes & Noble came to town
and they weren't able to
compete with the title selection
or prices that Barnes & Noble offered.
- [Narrator] The big stores
and large inventories
weren't enough to save Barnes
& Noble from a digital threat.
- Amazon was able to offer,
kind of like Barnes & Noble had
in the past, a huge selection
of titles at lower prices
than Barnes & Noble could
because it didn't have the cost
of real estate
and other costs that Barnes
& Noble was shouldering.
- [Narrator] And it sunk a lot
of money trying to keep
pace, particularly in NOOK,
its e-reader business.
- [Announcer] Take your story
wherever you want it to go.
- [Narrator] But nothing
helped stop the bleeding.
The company's revenue
has declined since 2012.
Then in 2019,
hedge fund Elliott Management
Corporation acquired the chain
and installed James Daunt
who led British Retailer Waterstones
and founded his own independent bookstore,
Daunt Books, as CEO.
- It felt entirely intuitive to me
that you allow each bookstore to run
as an independent bookstore.
They will create much more
interesting, much more dynamic,
much more engaging bookstores.
- [Narrator] And that
meant reminding people
about the appeal of in-person
versus online shopping.
- What you're missing is
the opportunity to kind
of read the book flaps of all
the other books that are there
and maybe get recommendations
from the local bookseller
who's working there.
- [Narrator] The company says
it wanted to emphasize the experience
of visiting a physical bookstore
so its new strategy strips
stores of the cookie cutter look
and feel that had helped
the chain grow its revenue
and store count.
Some locations have moved on
from the big box model to smaller stores.
- And in these smaller spaces,
they are reconfiguring the stores
so that they're more of maze
and less of a supermarket aisle.
- [Narrator] Plus, the company
says each individual store
has more autonomy
over what books to order
and how to display them.
Here at the Pikesville, Maryland location,
the store manager says that customers
like romance, books from Black
authors and lots of fiction.
So the large romance section
is at the front of the store
and there's a huge display right
in the center celebrating
Black History Month.
Store managers can also
choose how to run promotions,
like this buy one, get one 50% off deal
on specific fiction books
chosen by the team here.
- Brooklyn has a very
different demographic,
very different set of
customers, a very different set
of book interests to let's say somebody
in Alabama, in Georgia.
Who is the best person
to judge what those particular
communities wanna buy?
It's the booksellers in those communities.
- [Narrator] The company
has also been listening
to its store managers on wider trends.
- Manga was a small
part of our assortment.
We had maybe five, six
bays of books on manga,
and yet when these booksellers
were reorganizing their stores,
they were coming back to us
saying, we want to do 38.
You know, we want to do 42,
which was just almost
sort of incomprehensible,
except that's what they
said their customers
would respond to.
- [Narrator] Daunt also used
this localizing strategy
to turn around British
bookstore chain Waterstones,
which reported a 42.91 million pound loss
across 268 stores in 2012 compared
to a 16.32 million pound
profit across 278 stores
six years later.
- The two businesses
are on paper identical.
It had had identical histories
and had reached an
identical point of failure.
- [Narrator] That's why Barnes & Noble
relinquished some control
to individual stores, but that comes
with its own set of
challenges for the company.
- You could walk into a
bookstore and find out
that it's really not doing well.
The manager's choices aren't appealing
to customers and books aren't selling.
- [Narrator] Still Barnes & Noble says
the strategy is promising.
For the first time in more than a decade,
the company is planning
on opening more stores
than it closes in 2023.
- We've seen a balancing in
which a much higher percentage
of our sales are coming from books
and books are growing
really very dramatically.
If you run better bookstores,
you sell more books.
(pensive music)